I want to introduce Dr Corso he's a
postdoctoral researcher here in the
Aeronautics and astronautics department
at Stanford University he's in
particular in the Stanford intelligence
systems laboratory under Michael
kochendorfer that is the lab here that
has the best pronounceable acronym which
is sizzle
he is also the executive director of the
Stanford for AI Sanford Center for AI
safety which is broadly the topic we're
going to be talking about today
his research is focused on the use of
algorithmic decision making for safety
critical applications emphasizing the
creation of robust reliable autonomous
systems and this is a really important
topic and obviously it's been important
for a long time and that's something
that Anthony and I will talk about a
little bit but it's also something
that's come to Greater prominence and we
are working with Anthony to create a
seminar that we'll be offering in the
last week of July on this particular
topic we'll talk a little bit more about
that at the end of the presentation but
if you're interested in learning more
about it there is you should see a a
little button right there on your screen
that you can click and that will take
you to the course page which has a rough
description of what that will look like
all right with that again I want to
remind you at any time feel free to ask
your questions but we'll I'm going to
just kick it off Anthony
um again thank you for joining us here
today and I think probably the place to
start is if you could just introduce
yourself a little bit more by talking
about your research
yeah thanks Pax uh and it's great to be
here thank you all um for choosing to
spend 45 minutes with us
um talking about this important topic so
um I did my uh Masters and PhD in the
Aeronautics and astronautics Department
um uh here at Stanford and a lot of the
the research that I did was thinking
about the ways in which we can use AI or
algorithmic decision making uh to
improve both the safety and efficiency
of Transportation Sims um so you know
something like a million people every
year die in car accidents um and so you
know if we can improve the safety of
things like driving cars uh then we can
save a lot of lives
um and so the topic that I I mostly
studied was around
um you know the use of AI systems to
perform these tasks safely but then the
question naturally naturally arises
um how do you check whether or not
you've built a very safe system so I I
did my dissertation work on developing
algorithms that allow you to stress test
and ensure the safety of uh these really
high stakes systems and since then I've
carried on as a postdoc and have
continued to think about uh kind of the
areas in which we use AI systems that
influence uh and affect a lot of people
and we really need to make sure that
they are robust and reliable before
deploying them
that's great so Anthony I think maybe we
can take a step back so there are kind
of a couple there are a couple things
there we already have a good question
just about some of the terminology uh
about you know what a what what it means
for a system to be robust
um but I think maybe we start is can we
can we dig a little bit deeper on
autonomous systems so you you primarily
worked with systems in transportation so
Cars airplanes drones those kinds of
things
um could you talk a little bit more
about autonomous systems and what you're
thinking of what that broadly covers and
what the risks are involved with those
you've already touched on it in terms of
car accidents
um but can you build on that a little
bit
yeah absolutely so I think of autonomous
systems as really any system that's
going to perform a task that
historically has been done by a human so
this can be
um driving cars is a prime example
um and autonomous systems um you know
although we've had autonomous systems
for a very long time
um people are think are becoming much
more aware of them with the Advent of AI
and machine learning which are
techniques that allow you know computer
systems to learn from data and basically
enable us to process information in real
time and enable this higher level of
autonomy that we've been seeing over the
past couple of years the problem is
however that a lot of these Technologies
although they are absolutely amazing and
enable us to do incredible things
um often fail in uh kind of unexpected
ways they tend to be a little bit more
brittle than say humans are so they may
work in a very controlled say laboratory
setting but as soon as you deploy these
systems and the environment changes ever
so slightly
um you can begin running into problems
and this is of course very dangerous uh
if you're deploying these systems uh in
a domain like driving where people's
lives
could you uh you know I actually have
something I want to Circle back onto
about about safety but could we could we
elaborate on the on the brittleness of
some of these systems can you build on
what that means so it sounded at the
core it just means it they fail in ways
that humans might not or is it that they
fail differently than humans or they're
more likely to fail or they just don't
they don't generalize I guess would be
the term maybe the way humans uh humans
might yeah so it can be a little bit of
both
um I'll start with maybe an example so
you know folks showed that for example
you can um maybe TR if you collect data
from um you know certain uh geographic
area let's say for maybe we're building
a system that can identify pedestrians
if you collect a bunch of data from a
certain geographic area and then you
train a machine learning model to detect
pedestrians you're likely to build a
very reliable uh model that can detect
pedestrian really well
um the problem is if you uh then try to
deploy that model and say a different
Geographic domain where things are
slightly different so maybe the
crosswalk looks a little bit different
or people tend to wear different clothes
or or something like that and all of a
sudden what we see is that these machine
learning models performances can drop
pretty dramatically even though the
differences in kind of the environment
are quite at all and humans don't really
have this problem we're able to
generalize fairly well across a variety
of facts
that's great and we're hard and thank
you again I want to remind you if you
have questions feel free to post them
we're already getting a a ton of those
but I want to build on this uh maybe a
little bit more and circle back to
something before we kind of move on is
you when you initially said it part of
what got you interested is not to ensure
the safety of AI systems but the way in
which AI systems or autonomous systems
can improve our safety right so could
you elaborate on that that kind of the
flip side so it's not just that you're
trying to ensure that systems are safer
but it's also the case that that maybe
AI systems can do things more safely
than humans potentially in certain
domains
absolutely so like one of the reasons
I'm so excited about
um AI in general is this possibility
that we can have systems that perform uh
for example much much better than a
human at a variety of tasks you really
care about so I think a great example of
this would be health care so if you
could have an AI system that was maybe
even just as good as as you know the
world's best doctor you could deploy
that system very widely across the world
providing Healthcare access to people
who wouldn't otherwise get it or
likewise you know flying aircraft or
flying or driving Vehicles these are
things that you know although humans do
fairly well we can really improve the
safety of and and that can be really
beneficial for everyone
um but of course as soon as you start
thinking in those terms you have to you
have to be careful because you know what
we're talking about with AI systems is
it allows it to you know allows us to
scale these systems out to very like a
ton of people and so then any risk
that's inherent in the system is now a
risk affecting many many more people and
so we have to be extremely careful
before actually deploying these systems
out into the world yeah
so that's really interesting so part of
it part of what the the particular
challenge of these systems is how
scalable they're that they are right so
you have if I make a mistake as a driver
it's I'm I'm a single driver right and
that potentially has local consequences
but it's not like I am driving
everyone's car whereas what you're
proposing is or what what people are
trying to achieve is a system that will
be you know deployed across all the
United States all over the world and so
the yeah and actually along those lines
uh another issue that another sort of um
problem that AI systems tend to face is
that they can be fairly susceptible to
what we call adversarial attack or
basically like intentional manipulation
um by people and so you know you can do
there's some been some research where
people can you know for example print
out a sticker that just kind of looks
like a you know maybe a sticker you
would see out in the world posted on a
stop sign and it can make a machine
Learning System think that that stop
sign is now a speed limit 45 side and so
this could be extremely dangerous and
like you said it's not just going to
affect that one system but if all the
cars on the road are using the same
algorithm then they can all be
influenced by this one sort of attack
and so that's one of the reasons why we
need to be extra careful with
um sort of testing and verification of
these systems
so I I do I wanna there's one particular
question I think is maybe before we kind
of move on is there's a question about
if there are additional risks for say
big trucks or little you know or
different kinds of vehicles on the road
and so could you just talk a little bit
about when you're thinking about
deploying these systems I mean
how how generalizable are these systems
across the classic vehicle those kinds
of things I mean what are what are some
of those considerations again we're
probably I guess here we're talking
about cars but it could apply to
airplanes right I mean can can the same
system go in a 747 versus Cessna and and
what are some of those considerations
yeah so so I think of of AI safety is
sort of like uh you know you have to
multiply sort of like the likelihood of
a failure event occurring times the
magnitude of the the consequences of
that failure event and together that
gives you sort of like your overall risk
um so if you think about a system like
an aircraft which has an extremely high
uh consequence if something goes wrong
because you know very bad things can
happen if you do something wrong on an
aircraft so you need a correspondingly
extremely small uh probability of
failure so the FAA for example
um tries to ensure that their systems
fail no more than one in about a billion
hours of flight time so it's you know
extremely extremely safe as we've all
come to expect now on the flip side of
that if you're thinking about you know
deploying a machine learning model to
say for example serve ads to users as
they come to your website the like the
risk of making a mistake there is
relatively low if you serve someone the
wrong ad
um perhaps they just don't look on on
the thing that you sell them and so the
risk is kind of low so we can tolerate
much higher rates of failure in domains
like that and I think that there's
basically a whole Spectrum here now
everyone you know once their their
machine learning model or AI system to
be as reliable as possible but it
becomes all the more important as those
consequences get higher and so to the
question around
um you know variety of road vehicles and
and things like that we have to think
about you know what is the domain in
which they're going to be operated and
so for example they're going to be
driving downtown city streets in New
York or are they going to be driving an
open pit mine where there aren't any
other people around
um and so the context really matters
when it comes to safety
that's great and we're getting a lot of
really good uh good questions but I I
want to uh maybe before getting to some
of those I do want to uh I want to
address something that's the
conversation we're having right now is
very and where your specialty is is
thinking about these autonomous systems
how to build Safe Systems and also how
to verify the safety of those systems
but right now obviously uh you know one
of the top hot topics on Twitter around
AI safety is this exercise is the
question of existential risk right is AI
going to you know you know this is like
the Terminator or Skynet uh scenario
could you talk a little bit about what
you're talking about what you'll be
teaching this summer and how it might or
might not relate to that question of
existential risk yeah absolutely so
maybe first I'll briefly articulate what
I think the argument around existential
risk is then I'll talk about how um the
the summer seminar might or might not
relate to that so so the basic idea is
that you know as we build more and more
capable and competent autonomous systems
that are more widely integrated into our
society uh the risk is that uh either
due to these problems of a lack of
robustness or what's often called a
misalignment in their objective so you
know we asked the super competent AI
system do one thing uh and in pursuit of
that one thing it maybe destroys a lot
of other things that we care about
um and so you know you know this is
something that that people are are
beginning to think more about as systems
get better and better over time but uh
the topic of my research is a little bit
divorced from that in that I think about
systems that are literally on the roads
today so for example you know you can
you can go to I think Phoenix and San
Francisco and actually get a
self-driving car with no safety driver
in it you can get in that car and it
will take you from
um so I'm sort of most concerned about
the systems that are out there in the
world today but what I will say is that
many of the problems that exist in these
systems like a lack of robustness or
security flaws and things of that nature
um could exacerbate this problem of
existential risk uh down the line when
we have more and more concrete systems
so I think thinking about these problems
early on is really important to kind of
mitigating those risks going forward as
well
that's great and do you know this is
kind of again on that high level uh you
know at this level where where does
ethics this is a question that came in
earlier from one of the uh the
participants where does ethics come in
or that that question
um you know how do you consider that or
think about that or is that maybe at a
level up from these very concrete sort
of technical problems that you're trying
to address
yeah so that's a fantastic question and
and it's an extremely important piece of
the whole deployment of AI systems
ensuring that these systems are deployed
in a way that's Equitable and fair to
all groups
um and in fact you know you can even
think about this the the risk that say
an AI system will will behave
differently it's uh different subgroups
of people based on gender or race or
something like that as essentially a
lack of robustness to uh you know uh
various subgroups
um and and so this is a problem that we
you know absolutely need to mitigate
it's a problem that comes from the data
sets that we as humans have generated
you know we have bias in our society and
that to show up in the data sets that we
made
um but it can also be issues with the
model uh or you know models that we use
to train on those data sets that will
pick up on spurious correlations and
things of that nature so
um so these are the types of problems
that
um we need to address and that we'll be
talking about in the seminar
can we dig on a little bit deeper on
those we're getting a lot of really
great questions so I'm just going to
summarize so there's some a lot of
questions about kind of specific
applications particularly around say uh
use in warehouses or industrial
Machinery so I think maybe we can come
back to that in in the end but my senses
is some of what you're working on
applies across these kinds of machines
so though your expertise is really in
working with you know self-driving cars
with with uh with uh Ava you know with
airplanes or drones my sense is it
applies across a a the the kind of
fundamental theoretical concerns that
you're addressing do apply across those
domains
um is That Could you actually before we
do that could we then perhaps take a
step back and just you've already
articulated but maybe articulating it
again so there are kind of two aspects
to this right there's building and
there's verification is that correct
you just touched on that so could you
elaborate when you're thinking about
designing an an AI system what are the
kind of steps or the the different
aspects where you're thinking about
safety and just building out on those
yeah absolutely that's that's a great
question so so first to your original
point I do think that a lot of what
we're about to talk about here basically
applies across all sorts of application
domains because a lot of the core
underlying technology is very very
similar
um so yeah as Pax mentioned uh the you
know you have two phases I would say uh
very broadly speaking when designing uh
an autonomous system for a high stakes
application the first is just building
that system
um and so when we build that system we
have to kind of uh do a variety of
things to ensure that we're building
kind of the best possible system so
maybe that means we're collecting data
and making sure we have enough data or
our data is diverse enough to cover all
the aspects of problem we're trying to
solve
um we need to ensure that we're using
kind of the the latest and greatest
methods engineering methods that are
known to kind of behave in a day for a
more reliable way
um and then once we've we've done that
so maybe we've created a system that
that we think is very safe because we've
used all of the practices we've
collected data we've done some
preliminary you know experimentation and
things seem to be going well
um but the second phase of this before
deployment is we really need to
understand what can go on what can go
wrong and what are the risks if we
deploy it
um and this can be a whole separate
um uh challenge so I'll actually give a
sort of a short anecdote to illustrate
this so so my advisor Professor Michael
cookendurfer
um helped develop uh the next generation
of aircraft collision avoidance um so
these are systems that are on board all
commercial aircraft that basically
ensure that if there's the potential for
some a mid-air Collision that it alerts
uh both Pilots to make a maneuver dude
or that that does not happen
um and so he started working on uh this
project uh
I believe around 2011 uh and they built
prototypes of it and they designed an
extremely safe system but it took an
additional eight years of verification
and validation to build enough trust in
that system to get the FAA stamp of and
this is already when the system was safe
enough they just had to ensure it you
know they had to build the trust in it
in order to make sure everyone was
confident that what they were deploying
was going to actually be safe and so so
both of those aspects the designing of
the system and the test and evaluation
are both crucial
um pieces of of eventually deploying a
safe system
and so and we're going to get into this
when we talk through the class but can
you talk a little bit more about the
verification piece I know you've done a
lot of work around that really
interesting work around formal
verification and as well as
um I I'm going to get this wrong but
like a is rare event or robust training
so could you talk a little bit about you
know maybe focusing on your research but
the kinds of things that are important
for verification both to ensure that a
system is safe but also and and we got a
question about selling AI but that's
kind of related to your last point but
also in communicating or showing and
demonstrating that safety to to people
who might be using it yeah that's a
great question so I'll talk a little bit
about my dissertation work uh because
it's very near to dear near and dear to
my heart um and so this is around you
know basically the analysis or the the
testing of extremely Safe Systems so for
example if we're designing a
self-driving car uh we want to make sure
that that self-driving car is much much
safer than a human
um so for example maybe we want it to be
10 times safer than the average human
driver and what that means is that uh
that this will have a basically a
failure rate of something less than uh
one in ten to the seven so one in 10
million uh chance of of say causing a
collision for every hour on the road
um and so this this poses a real
challenge because you know uh if I make
a system how do I know that it's going
to fail only one in ten to the seven
rather than one and ten to the six you
know I would have to drive that car uh
hundreds of millions of miles to ensure
that it was hitting that correct level
of safety and so this is the problem
that we call in sort of the research
Community
um the problem of rare events so these
failure events are extremely rare and if
we were to just sort of naively go
throughout our day maybe simulating our
our autonomous vehicle in sort of
nominal conditions we're very unlikely
to encounter these failure events
um so the focus of my dissertation work
was around how can we uh actually
increase the likelihood of encountering
one of these failure events and the way
we did this was actually handing control
over the environment and and the
environment in this case with this stuff
uh maybe pedestrians on the on the road
other vehicles on the road uh maybe
weather and lighting conditions things
that could affect the performance of our
of our automated vehicle
um and we would uh hand over those those
aspects of the environment to a another
AI agent and that AI agent would be
trained to try to uncover failures of
the system so it would actually try to
manipulate the environment in such a way
as to cause our autonomous vehicle to
fail
um so it's kind of you know a little bit
backwards we think of AI as you know
doing uh what it can to say avoid
collisions or something like that but
this was using AI to actually cover the
weaknesses of our automated vehicle and
we can do and when we do that we can
uncover a whole bunch of possible
failure modes and when we do we can
basically allows us to understand what
are the weakness of our system are we
okay with uh the failure modes that we
found or do we need to go back to the
drawing board and fix some of these uh
these days before we deploy it
and that's great and so and could we
okay so there's this kind of the
question you've got rare events you're
going to be testing is something that's
so safe that in theory that you know the
kinds of events that that that cause a
failure are really really rare and so
how do you you know how do you uncover
those before they happen I'm assuming
this could also in theory be applied to
non-ai systems right you could you I
assume a similar model could be used to
to stress test structures to stress
tests not stress tests but to test the
modeling of a structure or just the
design of a mechanical system
uh indeed so so you definitely could do
that um the the difference is that in
oftentimes in more traditional systems
you don't need this approach because you
can reason about the safety of the
system from sort of first principles
like you know what it's made up of maybe
it uses gpps we know the characteristics
of GPS we can kind of Reason about its
safety uh in that way uh the difference
here is that you know now these say
autonomous vehicles are based off these
very complex machine learning components
which are these black box models that
are very difficult to reason about
um and so we need to kind of begin
coming up with other ways of testing
these systems and what I describe is one
way that's really interesting so again
it's it's in we I'm going to call it and
this is not technical because I've got
technical the kind of traditional
systems you can reason as you said from
first principles we understand the
physics well enough of this mechanical
system that we can predict the failure
points with an AI system we can't reason
about it based on first principles so we
need to we need to to test it in
simulations could we build on that
because I know you've also or Michael's
lab has also done work around formal
verification could you tell us a little
bit about that what that means and how
you're using that or how people could
use that to test systems yeah absolutely
so so formal verification is just like a
fancy research term uh for mathematical
proofs so what we're doing in formal
verification is trying to construct a
mathematical proof that the system has
the safety behavior that we want to do
so for example we might try to construct
a proof that our vehicle will never
collide with another vehicle now this
may sound challenging or or
um and it is uh and oftentimes what's
required to do these formal verification
proofs is to make a bunch of assumptions
so we will maybe we'll assume that
pedestrians can only move so fast and
that they'll only move in a particular
direction and so on and so forth and so
we make all these assumptions and then
we prove that our system under those
assumptions will never ever be involved
in a collision
um now the problem is uh number one that
if those assumptions are ever violated
then we no longer have those guarantees
but that that could be okay because at
least we know we're safe when the
assumptions are holding and then when
the assumptions are violated we can you
know perhaps take some evasive maneuver
or identify or alert someone that there
could be a potential problem
um
and so so that's what we mean by formal
verification and it's been a really
useful tool to basically proving uh
properties of various components that
have gone into Aviation systems as well
as a ton of vehicles uh to kind of uh
provide a boundary over which we know we
are safe and that can be really really
useful
that's fantastic
um yeah and I think those are two really
interesting things I should point we
have a link to it to Anthony's bio there
so if you want to dig in deeper I think
there are some links to your CV and some
of the papers that you've uh you've
published or or also to the the sizzle
the Stanford intelligence systems
laboratory as well if people are
interested in sort of digging deeper
into some of those topics
um we're getting a lot of good questions
but I I think uh you know maybe we can
actually circle into and come back to
some of these questions but I I want to
circle into the course that you're
you've been planning and trying to
develop uh for this summer and so maybe
we can you can just walk through because
I think in walking through that you're
going to be expanding on this
conversation we've been having and
talking about having and talking about
kind of what goes into building a safe
and verifying a safe system so can you
talk through what you're thinking about
in terms of the content this is a short
one week class right so it is it is
technical but it's obviously you know
it's not a semester-long or anything
like that so could you yeah
absolutely so
um the reason I'm putting together this
course maybe I can start there um is
because I think that um there's a lot of
great resources out there on uh the
internet through scpd for example where
you could learn about how to apply
machine learning uh and AI to solve a
variety of problems um and I remember
taking one of these courses uh several
years back and thinking wow this is
really incredible I can't believe how
sort of straightforward and easy it is
to apply these techniques and solve real
world problems
um the issue is that in in the years
since then and I've you know I've now
built a lot of machine learning systems
and AI systems um uh you begin to
discover that the devil is often in the
details so there's a lot of issues that
can go wrong when you actually go to try
to deploy or or build the system for
real world problem
um and so I've kind of collected you
know a number of learnings from from my
years and doing research in this topic
and I wanted to put those learnings into
kind of one place where someone who's
maybe taken some machine learning
courses can go to get up to speed on
kind of the latest uh kind of
advancements but also current issues
around yeah I'm sure and so to that end
um you know we we've outlined basically
a five-day course each day we'll you
know consist of about two hours of
lectures
um on the first day we're going to be
talking about
um sort of an introduction to uh the use
of AI and safety critical domains and
I'll walk through some some examples of
times where AI has failed the machine
learning models have failed um and then
talk about how you know what are some of
the techniques that we can use uh to
build much more robust machine learning
models that don't suffer from some of
the problems that we've seen quite so
much
um can you define robust a little bit
that was one of the first questions oh
yeah
so when I say robust what I mean is uh
that the model will or the an AI system
will have similar performance uh even
when the environment in which it's
operating in changes ever so slightly
um so like I said you know a robust
model say for autonomous driving will do
just as well in the morning as it does
in the afternoon when the lighting
conditions are different and people's
behavior are slightly different
um that's what sort of we mean by
robustness
um great so then and the the next uh two
days will be around model evaluation and
verification so on that on uh the next
day we'll be talking about
um techniques for explaining uh these
machine learning models so as I said you
know often these are these very complex
uh neural networks that have you know uh
billions potentially of of parameters
that are used to process images
um and they're often thought of as is
too complex to really think about but
but people have been developing ways to
sort of peer inside the Black Box a
little bit and try to understand a
little bit more about how these machine
learning components are arriving at the
decisions that they have
um we'll also be talking a little bit
about uh this question of failure
identification so using these sort of
adversarial techniques to kind of stress
test your system to uncover the ways in
which it might fail as a tool to to kind
of eventually build Safe Systems
um and then we will be talking about
um
methods informal verification as well so
certifying uh or you know mathematically
proving that our neural networks uh are
resilient to say adversarial attacks and
have other properties that we desirable
and we'll get to play with some
libraries that people have developed to
do this so you can actually use it in
real world projects that you might be
working on
um on day four then we're going to move
into a discussion on uncertainty
quantification machine learning so I'll
say a little bit about what I mean so
uncertainty quantification is basically
you know what happens when your machine
learning model say encounters the
situation it's never seen before would
you want on the one hand for it to just
decide what it thinks is best and and go
forward full steam or would you want it
to identify the fact that it's in a
novel situation and perhaps uh maybe
alert a human supervisor or basically do
something that it knows to be um and in
the latter case that's the use of
uncertainty quantification where it's
uncertain about what it's doing and so
you know you put on the brakes and make
sure things are okay and so there's a
bunch of techniques for building this
style of reasoning about uncertainty
into the machine learning components or
the AI systems that you build
is it's it's the idea you're in a new or
novel situation
um it's one recognizing I suppose this
is probably a problem just recognizing
it's a new situation and then two is
knowing how to respond to that and it
can be are we think our system is still
reliable in this or it's alert a human
or I know I don't remember if this is
something that Sizzle works on but it
could be something like reverting from
the the AI system to a a model that's
much safer or to a safer parameters or
something like that indeed yeah often
these systems are built with like what
they call fallback strategies so like if
everything else goes wrong we have a
fallback strategy that we know to be
safe though it's going to be much less
uh uh effective than your AI policy
um but the real challenge often is is
identifying the situations that are uh
novel you would think that this should
be again something easy to do because
humans do it very regularly we know when
we're in a situation that we don't
understand
um machine learning models have kind of
a bizarre attribute where they may be
extremely confident in in a decision
they're making even though it's very
uncertain and they're wrong so you know
there's there's uh there's potential for
you know major downsides if you don't
take this into account explicitly
that's great I'm sorry to interrupt you
I just thought that was one more thing
don't worry a little bit more yeah and
happy to answer more questions about
that um and then on uh we'll kind of tie
it all together on the last day where
we'll talk about
um for example the uh uh aircraft
Collision avoiding system that I
mentioned early earlier we'll use that
as a case study to think about you know
how you put all these pieces together in
a way that killed a very reliable Sim um
and then I'll talk a little bit about
some of the upcoming
um regulation around AI so there's
actually some uh you know there's a big
law that's soon to be signed uh in the
EU and then there's been some
discussions here in the U.S and thinking
about the ways in which AI might be
regulated and how some of the techniques
describing perhaps will fit into that
regulation because you might be required
in the future to do many of the things
I'm talking about to ensure that you
know people say unharmed for the systems
that we build
thanks uh Anthony so it's it's a really
interesting course and again it's
focusing on kind of these autonomous
systems I guess one thing is do you see
so you know we're talking in the primary
use case we're talking about is is is uh
is autonomous vehicles like cars or
Aviation we got a lot of questions about
working in warehouses uh maybe
industrial Machinery does this still
apply I mean in some sense that's a much
more controlled environment than a road
where you have pedestrians where the you
know the the the the entire kind of
infrastructure is not built around AI
whereas when you go into a factory the
the the infrastructure can be designed
around the systems themselves right and
so I guess the broadly the question is
how do these apply to those kinds of
systems that are or situations that are
more controlled do you think it's still
applicable to people who are interested
in machine learning and Industrial
applications
yeah absolutely so I think you know
almost everything will uh apply so I
mean it just to varying degrees so as
you mentioned in the autonomous driving
setting you're in a very open and
uncontrolled environment so lots of
stuff can go wrong lots of things can
change over time and I think it's one of
the reasons why it's taken such a long
time to get autonomous vehicles out on
the roads operating safely
um in a much more controlled environment
you do have the luxury of perhaps
controlling the the environment in which
the AI system is operating in
um but it's never so straightforward as
that things will always jam and and you
want your your AI system say that's
controlling a robotic arm to be somewhat
resilient to the small changes that
occur on the factory line or changes to
the environment
um lighting conditions you know seasonal
changes things like this
um you might for example not be so
worried about that you know I talked a
little bit about what I call adversarial
attacks but there's some sort of
intentional regulation or AI system
maybe that's less of a concern in the uh
in the warehouse domain than it would be
in the driving domain
um but nonetheless you know you still
want to have as robust of a system as
possible
um in both of those applications it's
just sort of to varying that's really
interesting how do you even I guess in
one cent one question of follow-up there
is how do you reason I mean do you
reason for first principles you talked
about using AI systems to kind of play
an adversarial role in manipulating a
simulated environment how do you even
figure out what parameters in that
environment to to sort of adjust now as
you're talking one thing that comes to
mind is you're say you're working in a
warehouse and say that warehouse it has
Windows right that are facing yeah you
might not think you wouldn't necessarily
think about daylight or you know
nighttime conditions being a significant
factor but it could be but how do you
you know how do you approach even
thinking through what the environment is
and what are the important changes to to
to control for or to test for
yeah that's that's a great question and
there's no easy answer you know it's
going to be a combination of
um the experts in the domain so people
who like have worked in the warehouse
you know space before and they
understand like what things might change
what are the common kind of uh
situations that might arise that maybe
would be challenging for a human to
handle and then you can infer that it
would also be challenging for this AI
agent
um you can uh look at a bunch of
examples and this is what we'll do in in
the course we'll look at a bunch of
examples where you have uh these what we
call distribution shifts so this is
where things in the environment change
ever so slightly and the Machine
learning models performance drops uh
quite a bit and so we'll look at a bunch
of examples of that you'll see you know
for example uh changes in lighting
condition or color scheme like like
things like this you can build a little
bit of an intuition around what types of
factors May influence certain types of
machine learning models
um and then the last piece of this is
like you absolutely need to monitor your
systems as you deploy them so you don't
know everything that's going to arise
um and so it's really important to build
in this element of number one
quantifying your uncertainty during
operation so like as we talked about
making sure the system is aware when
things change and can potentially alert
say a user uh and then also having
systems that are are monitoring the
uh the performance of these systems over
time and if you see the performance
dropping for example then you know
something has shifted maybe it's time to
retrain your model or or intervene in
some way
that's great so maybe even revisiting
when I talked to you when I mentioned
earlier kind of the the aspects of it
there's building there's verification
and then is is monitoring almost maybe a
third thing there right you're verifying
it in advance and once it's deployed
it's making sure you have and this is
what you're talking about in in terms of
uncertainty quantification You're
Building into that system away to
monitor to flag uh situations that are
outside what would be a normally uh uh
considered it would be considered normal
yeah yeah so that that's like one aspect
of what we call runtime monitoring um is
that uncertainty quantification piece
that can alert when something is has
gone off nominal but another thing you
can do is just every you know every so
often every week or something uh you
know uh uh reevaluate your say model on
a new set of data so it's sort of like
just a repeated validation process so
doing the same thing you did you know
before you deployed it just you know on
an iterated base to ensure that things
are staying at a highway level of
performance so this would be so in other
words the AI system is running it's
doing its thing it's not retraining
itself as it's doing it it's not so to
speak learning typically environment but
what you're doing is collecting more
data then re-testing it on the new data
um exactly yeah I you know I this is a
little bit of a of a I I just find it as
a really fascinating idea uh and it's
related to that is this idea of just I
think it's called distributional shift
is what you you've talked about
um yeah so I guess the the idea is uh
it's related to this to uncertain or
novel situations but it can also be that
maybe the AI system is working well but
say that the camera that's that's
recording it is degrading and so the
quality of the image is changing can you
talk a little bit about that and and
maybe this idea of distributional shift
or maybe I'm focusing on the wrong thing
but just how that can affect the safety
or the continued operation in the
machine it might not just be changes
environment it could be changes in the
sensors I guess yeah absolutely so it
could be changes in in the sensors and
I've talked a lot about sort of these
physical changes in the environment like
you know changing lighting conditions
and things like that but distribution
shift can be uh something that happens
say like like imagine for example that
we have a um an AI system that's helping
you diagnose uh new diseases at a
hospital or something
um what would you think would happen to
that system uh at the beginning of the
covid-19 pandemic for example where a
new you know a new virus altogether has
shown up on the scene it would make
these systems go Haywire because it's
not they've never seen that before and
so it can be things like that where like
the distribution of inputs that it's
seeing is Shifting because of a new
thing in the world or anything like that
interesting yeah so it's a completely
new right I hadn't even thought about
that if there's a new disease or
something like that that's introduced it
could completely change the way it's
diagnosing everything uh yeah yeah
that's that's really so we're that's
great Anthony and we're nearing the end
of our time so maybe you know we've
gotten a couple questions about this uh
so maybe if we in these last couple
minutes uh if you we could do just a
kind of a big kind of zoom out and away
from the kind of the specific things and
just maybe get your thoughts on what the
future of autonomous systems are what
you're hopeful about and what you're
worried about
yeah absolutely so so as I said at the
top you know I'm really hopeful that
that the use of that AI systems can
basically uh do a bunch of things uh
that humans historically have done so
they can do them perhaps more quickly
more efficiently at a larger scale and
this can bring a lot of great resources
to a lot of people
um so I think that's like the the thing
that everyone is shooting for
um but there are a ton of risks and I
think you know something we haven't even
talked about today
um though I'm sure everyone has kind of
encountered it recently is things like
chat GPT so these uh generative AI
systems that are able to produce content
text or images or videos and things like
that
um and you know these types of systems
when deployed Without You Know Much
oversight can lead to very
um strange and bad things happening so
if you know they can exhibit toxic
behavior
um they can discriminate against people
they can
um you know steal people's uh like
copyrighted information you know using
images that are in the style of an
artist or something like that they can
be used to intentionally produce
misinformation and they can do this at
scale like we talked about you know it's
something that a human typically does
but now you can do it incredibly fast
and widespread so
um I I'm a little bit worried that that
especially generative AI systems are uh
being deployed very widely very quickly
and we're not exactly sure what kind of
influence it's going to have on our
information ecosystem so now there's a
ton of AI generated content out in the
world and it's not always so obvious
when you're interacting so that's
definitely one of one concerns that I
have
do you think that this course so coming
back to the course do you think that
that some of these principles could also
apply to people who are thinking about
something you know we were talking about
cars and and machines you know things
that are interacting with the physical
environment and humans and there is you
know is that something that you think
some of these principles can apply to
something like chat GPT can you can you
do testing for kind of emotional harm to
humans that's a real that's a I guess
it's a tricky question it's much less
yeah a little bit a less tractable
problem maybe yeah yeah it's much less
cut and dry because it's not clear these
systems are very um general purpose like
it can do a lot of different things
um whereas the systems I was just
describing earlier have like sort of one
task that you can kind of check its
performance against
um and so you know so I think many of
the techniques can and will apply to
things like chat gbt but it's just a
more challenging domain because you know
it's very difficult to to quantify like
the harms on a societal scale and all of
these things but
um I think you know it's still you want
chat for example you want chat gbt to be
uh more robust and that it shouldn't Its
Behavior shouldn't substantially change
when it's interacting with tickle
um you would want it to express
uncertainty when it doesn't know
something sometimes it does I don't know
if you've seen it it'll say oh I'm not
sure about this
um uh and you would want it to be
truthful and honest and things like that
and so so I think many of the in
principle many of these techniques apply
but it does get a lot Messier when we're
talking about these really large scale
generative AI systems
how how uh can you know do you foresee
these generative AI systems being
applied in domains like autonomous
vehicles or or does that itself pose too
great a safety risk I'm sorry now we're
going a little bit off no it's fine I
um I certainly hope not that they are
not because it's uh you know I've seen
so many examples of failures of
reasoning failures of logic with these
systems that we don't want to put them
behind the wheel or behind the aircraft
um it's possible that you know if we you
know five ten years from now as these
systems get better and better they will
be more human-like in their reasoning
capabilities and and therefore could be
tested to do something like this but
we're definitely not there yet and I
think it's really important for
for these these tasks that are safety
critical and have high stakes that we
still stick with the kind of systems
that have been designed for this bespoke
purpose not these General AI systems
well thank you uh thank you Anthony for
joining us today and thank all of you
who joined us today for this uh this
fireside chat with with Anthony though
there's no fire I guess the uh the
suicide chat the online side chat well
thank you again everybody thank you
Anthony and we really appreciate your
time and maybe we'll see you again soon
yeah thanks everyone appreciate it